[Musique]
sur les murs du cetade qui veut dire
quartier général
une tapisserie représentant le corps
féminin est chargé de messages sans
équivoque sur la condition des femmes en
Iran
au milieu d'affiche de prisonniers
politiques des Iraniens de tous les âges
se réunissent chaque jour son ensemble
vraiment responsable d'être là jour
après jour parce que je suis iranienne
c'est mon c'est mon sur mon pays
certains ont connu l'installation de la
République islamique en 1979
espère un changement de régime après 40
ans de répression assez c'est assez
et cette fois-ci les jeunes
[Musique]
et pour conjurer la distance qui les
sépare dès lors les bénévoles
s'organisent en petits groupes en
solidarité avec leurs compatriotes qui
réclament plus de liberté ne sont petits
mais nous sommes effectifs et nous
sommes forts et c'est ce qui compte
vraiment certains s'occupent des
relations avec les médias d'autres
planifient les manifestations à venir
d'autres encore fabriquent des objets
promotionnels être impliqué dans les
rues de mon pays ça met en colère
ici tout est fait pour que la répression
en Iran ne tombe pas dans l'oubli
j'essaie d'être la voix des jeunes
personnes qui sont qui sont tués dans ce
temps en Iran Mac à 19 ans dont 10
passés au Québec de l'Iran elle garde
des souvenirs d'enfance parfois
difficiles pour nous c'était difficile
d'être à l'école
à cause que à cause de la part du hijab
ont été imposées des mauvaises
mentalités regardez nos ongles pour
qu'on a pas du vernis on pouvait pas
être nous-mêmes c'était des robes de
mariage de montante cette frustration
charzade archadi 72 ans la partage elle
aussi
plusieurs nuits que je pleure
parce que je pense que je dois être là
je pensais pourquoi je suis ici
militante de la première heure et la
manifester avec la jeunesse étudiante
gauchiste je suis photographe d'abord
contre le Shah d'Iran puis contre la
Roumanie avant de quitter le pays
[Musique]
vous avez perdu beaucoup de vos amis
beaucoup
mon frère qui est il avait 14 ans il est
il était en prison
il était une très fort il était très en
forme quand il était en prison après une
sortie il était comme ça
beaucoup de
torturent
des années plus tard c'est à travers
l'objectif de sa caméra qu'elle milite
pour casser l'image de victimes des
femmes iraniennes et la suivi des
combattantes du Kurdistan iranien les
pêche mergat dans le maki où il résiste
au régime des Molas qui des persécutent
retrouve ce même courage chez les
manifestantes qui descendent aujourd'hui
dans la rue ça c'est une révolution
féministe ils sont changés le mot
féministe pour moi
mais cette fois je pensais je suis très
proche en attendant de retourner un jour
en Iran charza de renoue avec ses
compatriotes le temps d'une soirée aux
États
où l'on répète une pièce théâtrale à la
mémoire des martyrs des récentes
contestations
2022 ce lieu est devenu un espace
d'expression et de rencontres de
personnes aux horizons divers qui
s'interrogent toutes sur l'avenir de
l'Iran
[Applaudissements]
besoin fort
d'abord
les discussions totalement ouvert et
vraiment cibler sur les sujets de
révolution d'aujourd'hui que vous parlez
de révolution vous y croyez
définitivement
révolution ce mot est sur toutes les
lèvres
je vais être libre avec lui les
personnes de mon pays
comme une incantation qui leur permet
d'espérer un avenir meilleur pour leur
pays
[Musique]